Hey, welcome back. So, we're working on
a 23 Honda Accord using the new type of
key. Smart Pro voltage. We're connected
with Wi-Fi. It looks like we're
connected. Let's see. Okay, it's going
in and out. Let's go back. And 23. Cool.
Now we're It's connected. Cool. Let's
get started. Press okay to
continue. Cool. Switch
on. Two taps. Dash is on. Good.
Cool.
Voltage. Honda prox keys. Cool. Let's
put that down. Yes. Connected to the
internet. Let me turn
off the AC. Switch on by two times.
Yes. Kind of like a regular Honda. Cool.
And switch off.
Off.
No. Make sure the regular proximity key
is in the vehicle. all the keys 10 ft
away. So, I'm going to take the new
key, Faraday bag, and just stick
it outside on the
ground. Okay, switch on. One, two. Dash
lights up.
Good. Cool. Remove all the
keys. Okay, this is the part where it's
different than the other ones. Remove
all the keys from the vehicle.
only bring in the new
key. So, I'm going to take that out.
Bring in the new
key. Put that down. So, the new key is
there. Hit. Okay. I think I'm in the
42nd
window. Let's see.
[Applause]
Do you want to program more proximity
keys? No. Switch
off. Switch on. One, two. Dash is on.
Good. Immobilizer light
is out.
Yes. Switch off.
Off. Switch back on. One, two. Dash
lights up. Good. And switch off again.
Let's just check in that new key.
Cool. Cool. Let's
check.
Cool. Cool. And we're good. Let's go
ahead and turn the vehicle
on. Yep, it turns on. It says ready.
It's an
EV. Cool. And we're good to go. Let's go
ahead and cut the key now and use the
keyline 30 or sorry the key line. Let's
go ahead and cut the key and use that
Jim Conor in the
Kjaw. Let's get ready to cut this key.
So, I'm going to click Honda Accord and
then we have this new type
2325 and
decode. Okay, so
now I need to insert the K jaw.
Ujaw out, Kjaw in. Now the the Kjaw is
in. We want you to pay attention to see
how the tip it's off center. We want to
pay attention to that orientation to
match the new key. The reason why is
look at that. See how that tip is
offset? We want to put in that way
first. So that's side
one. And then we took it out, flipped
it, and put in side two. As you see,
it's a different
cut. So, the Jim Condo will never show
the code for this. I don't know why.
It's just not given. Kind of like a
Subaru. So, if we look at side two, the
part we just did. So, side two is here.
What you see here, that looks correct
where it's
133. Cool. And let's flip this
over. Does that pattern look correct?
Yep. Let's go ahead and cut it.
[Music]
And we're done. We cut
it and we're good to go. Other than
that, have a great day and I'll see you
next time. See you. Bye.